the truth is that I defend the BBC I
think the BBC is fundamentally important
to the to this country and our strength
as a democracy and what has happened
today is I'm afraid the consequence of
creeping right-wing authoritarianism in
this country the people who should be
leaving the BBC are not garenica not Ian
Wright not Alan Shearer Richard Sharp
the chairman the Tory donor the friend
of sunac the man who arranges loans for
Boris Johnson Robbie Gibb the man who
used to work in that building where you
are Mark millbank and run BBC political
coverage and be perfectly happy for
people to be saying that the BBC was
full of left-wing pinkos while he was
campaigning for brexit and campaign for
the Tories then goes to work for Theresa
May now back on the board and Anna is
absolutely right this is pandering
cowering in the face of right-wing
extremism we have a right-wing extreme
authoritarian Fringe in the conservative
party that has got a grip of sunac that
got rid of Theresa May the in Johnson
that got in trusts and who's next Who's
Next as she said David Attenborough his
program's being watered down because
they're worried about the right way
you're going to say about climate change
Alan sugar who tweeted some vile things
about Jeremy corbyn when he was leader
now I would defend his right to do that
but what's the difference the difference
is that this government and their
wretched right-wing Rags who support
them their propaganda arm like the male
the express Etc they've created a fuss
loud enough for the BBC to go oh no it's
not going away we better get it right
but isn't it but isn't this much more
isn't this just a simple case of the BBC
um having its impartiality rules and one
of its major faces in their view has
broken those impartiality rules it's as
simple as that in their view in the
BBC's view okay if they're trying to
they're trying to negotiate with Gary
lineker and saying look if you row this
back you know we've we can still carry
on but it doesn't seem to be an
understanding of what he is prepared to
do it's as simple as that really isn't
it
well two things to say to that one is if
that's what's happened that they've
asked Gary to tone things down and he
said no then what it shows that he's got
values and principles in a way that they
don't and this government certainly
doesn't and the second thing I'd say is
if that's the case when I was involved
in the people's vote campaign Gary
lineker did an event with us he was very
very clear where he's there's no more
controversial issue than brexit and he
got involved in that
if it's a principle at stake here the
BBC should have pulled him aside then
but they didn't why because there was no
big deal there was no big fuss there was
no government that wanted us to talk
about this rather than The Wretched
useless riddled with holes illegal
migrants bill
well as well
there's a different director General who
is making you know who wants to make
more of this whole impartiality issue
and his you know talk to journalists and
he's talked to his current affairs
presenters about
um impartiality and you know they think
that Gary lineker's Fallen foul of that
and it doesn't matter that he's a sports
presenter he is a member of the BBC a
face of the BBC
okay well look I liked him Davey I think
he's a good bloke I think he's
absolutely committed to the BBC but I'm
afraid he is making a complete and total
mess of this and I suspect he's making
it because of the feeling of these right
wing pressures from people like Richard
Sharp and Robbie Gibb I'm afraid that
they are the people who should be going
and look I accept that this is difficult
it's a difficult issue social media has
made it more difficult but don't don't
devise your principles in quotes
according to the noise that's going on
around you devise your principles and
then stick to them what are the values
because I'm afraid they're just showing
such inconsistency if Gary lineker had
done something wrong when he did that
first tweet the BBC should have been
onto it straight away I know for a fact
that they weren't they wanted to see
whether the storm would blow over that
is no way to run a big organization like
the BBC and I'll tell you who is next
who is next is let's take let's let's
just take this to his logical conclusion
take Martin constant he's an actor in
line of duty which is one of the BBC's
most successful programs is a massive
export it's an incredible success story
Martin Constance is a very very big SNP
supporter
and no no nothing wrong with that he
fights for Independence nothing wrong
with that but there's there come a point
where the BBC thing oh my God that
Martin constant he's getting a bit
political Brian Cox Brian Cox the
scientist one of the well again a
massive Global asset for the BBC he
hates brexit and he never stops saying
it is he going to be stopped from saying
that and otherwise look it's there it's
clearly riddled with inconsistencies the
whole issue is riddled with
inconsistencies but the BBC has decided
Tim Davey whoever's decided that they
um can't have a view that he can't have
a view on issues
um that relate to Party politics or
political controversy they've decided
that and if they've decided that
um what do you think Gary lineker should
do
well
I suspect because Gary lineker does have
values and does have principles I
suspect we've seen him on much of the
day for the last time and I suspect that
with Alan Shearer
and and may I may I thank and praise him
for that because I think he's he's doing
there's a very famous phrase from the
30s Mark never be a bystander never be a
bystander we're watching we're watching
the creeping authoritarianism within
this government yeah we see it we see it
in some of the language soon that used
yesterday we see it in every time
Braverman opens them out we see it today
with Johnson's people Nadine dorries and
these other Nobis has been nobodies who
should never have been near government
trying to jumping up and down the
celebration done so this is creeping
authoritarianism so and Isis I so sorry
to interrupt but so if there was a BBC
Sports presenter tweeting out
support for the conservative government
you'd be quite happy with with that
B
up and down and say that guy should
never be on television again we had it
the whole time also he had all sorts of
people that were against the government
we were in power we had comedians we had
you know Jim Davidson did we go around
saying we don't Jim well actually Jim
Davidson probably shouldn't be on telly
because he's a crap comedian but we
didn't do that this law honestly they
think that unless you are 100
lining up behind whatever the
gaslighting LIE they are telling on that
particular day there's something wrong
with you and I hope honestly Mark I
really hope this is a wake-up call to
our media I really do when Johnson was
prime minister the guy who we all now
know was a complete liar corrupt a
charlatan all right he was no let me let
me finish the point and he was treated
he was treated by the news organizations
like every word had to be treated as a
gospel let me tell you something else
there were two big things happened this
week we've got to end it at some stage
but just by briefly can I finish it can
I finish this this one point yeah
briefly okay one one point very very
briefly there's another big story about
the media that's out there this week
this had no coverage whatsoever from a
bit of take up in the in the times I
think it was that Boris Johnson is
trying to get a date appearish for Paul
Baker at the Daily Mail the Daily Mail
which is hounding Gary lanika front page
after front page after front page a
corrupt disgraced prime minister trying
to honor a man for covering up the
investigation into his corruption okay
tell me which is worse